the gyro can experience what you're
doing with this book is essentially you
have a magnifying glass on some of the
worst aspects of human behavior is it
depressing kind of it's you know it's
kind of depressing I've also had people
tell me the book is infuriating which um
you know I really didn't intend that I I
kind of thought well let me tell you
when I first imagined this book I
imagined that we were gonna go through a
climate denial we were gonna snap out of
it because it was so obviously suicidal
and then we were gonna look around and
go how did that happen and how do we
make sure that never happens again and I
would be able to say look here are some
factors that have contributed to this
throughout history and here's you know
maybe this will lead to some reforms and
obviously it didn't work out that way
this book has come out when we have a
climate denier running the country he
has called it a hoax several times now I
think maybe he's been talked out of
using that term lately but he's still
pushing back the regulations really
changes I he's I said that several times
and and I know at least been one one
tweet maybe more a Chinese hoax that
China was trying to perpetrate on us so
so in any event you know it I I wrote an
infuriating book I didn't mean to I
meant to write a kind of let's all step
back and look at this sort of book but
it just turns out you cannot write about
infuriating topics without writing a
kind of infuriating book I do try to
keep some perspective here and and you
know look at look at the good parts of
this history which is to say in each
case you have members of the public you
have scientists you have journalists you
have movements stepping up and
confronting that denial and eventually
in most cases overcoming it and you know
we do have other segments of our society
that are designed to try to not just
pursue profit but to seek truth of
scientists and and journalists and that
doesn't mean they're not also trying to
pursue profit sometimes or at least get
paid for their work but you know we do
have
systems in place that have successfully
confronted this and so it's not like
we're starting from scratch
we are just in a very big hole right now
and particularly about climate change
and particularly with so much corporate
power over Congress and frankly the
states as well what what subjects were
have where you see there's actually
progress been made well you know people
have been fighting climate change on the
state level and we have done some things
also federally for a long time over the
years I mean many many states have put
in place climate targets to reduce their
greenhouse gas emissions many have put
in place renewable energy standards
which have been enormous ly successful
in building up the wind industry the
solar industry and and those
technologies as they deploy and improve
have gotten so much cheaper I mean it's
really much much easier now to imagine
getting rid of fossil fuels than it was
you know 40 years ago when the industry
first confronted this or when society
first really started looking at this and
the federal level they they've made
major improvements in they've required
efficiency standards which have been
really helpful for like major appliances
we had auto efficiency standards now
Obama put some strong ones in place
Trump has rolled those back again so
that's going to limit the the progress
exactly when it needs to be accelerated
so that's that's maybe not another good
good piece of some news you were asking
about we have well I mean I think that's
going to be largely the focus and even
though we have the trumpet said we're
not going to be part of the Paris
agreement anymore which by the way every
other country in the world you know is a
part of there's a handful that haven't
ratified it but everybody else is part
of it even though he said that you have
many states and in many cities stepping
forward and saying well we are still
part of it and we are going to be
working to reduce our emissions so you
know that's all very good news the
technology that we do have a deep bench
of policy experience we we know a lot of
good things that we can do that will
work and we have the rising concern the
youth movement
all around the world really that who are
really stepping up and say enough we
have got to deal with this and we've got
to deal with it now and because you
grown-ups have wasted 30 years we've got
to deal with it particularly
aggressively
[Applause]